hey house go press my name complete the
[ __ ] happened
oh god I'm put a pie all right friends
we got a brand new well it's probably
none you alright brush we got an awesome
cool awesome cool really good job this
is a really cool game it's called
universe sandbox and it is exactly that
it just came out on Steam and this is
our universe it's pretty cool there's my
anus let's go whoever named that planet
must be so [ __ ] proud to get away
with that [ __ ] so I know you can do a
bunch of stuff over we can add Venus to
orbit we can add a lot of Venus's that's
pretty cool let's add some herbs man you
really get a good perspective while
playing this this is really cool let's
get a march in there Mars pretty cool
let's put a Mars inside Mars D says
Christ what did I do
I'm sorry can we slow it down the time
no it just goes faster I think this is
why I should never be gone alright I
think this proves the point pretty well
it's so pretty
this is why I should have not any
control ever ever like I can't even
control the cookie jar how am I supposed
to control the universe it's pretty
though oh that one is just bye-bye
left the orbit I really want to slow
down the time though oh god what
happened did a Sun explode Jesus Christ
what the [ __ ] hahaha oh my god I did
rule my god it's so pretty
only it's so fluent this game is so
[ __ ] cool is that another galaxy
can't me just scroll over there
let's do
let's open an existing simulating a
simulator supernova Jesus Christ oh I
can change here how many steps per
second per millisecond Jesus a so cool
[Music]
what a brilliant game I'm sold
Jupiter in between Suns
there's Jupiter in between two cents
speed it up a lot man it's kept in place
because of the gravity that's pretty
[ __ ] cool
look at that ha and it's always bright
it's pretty cooking though oh my god
I'm blown away seriously go check out
this game that right now it's beets
[ __ ] watching me be an idiot I don't
even know what I'm doing but I'm getting
emotional and [ __ ] this music is just so
collapsing what is this oh my god I can
change all these aspects of the oh my
god like what else would you make a
sandbox of why not do universe a sphere
of a thousand planets come on oh my god
Jesus are they crashed they're crashing
oh my god I feel the power my framerate
is fair oh man I wish I had a better
computer I almost want to just upgrade
my computer to try this [ __ ] out look at
this Jesus Christ what the [ __ ] okay
my poor computer who can't simile oh god
I need to get out of this fast
Saturn gimme Saturn Earth and five
thousand moons yeah that's a good idea
to simulate okay here we got this this
should work better let's do four hundred
moons
maybe we can handle that [ __ ] yeah we
can here's earth let's find Cody pie
there we go somewhere here oh god
they're crashing oh [ __ ] they're
crashing Oh crashing to the earth what
the [ __ ] that's terrifying look at that
oh god we're all gonna die oh god we're
[ __ ]
damn it be worth it though it'd be
[ __ ] spectacular oh [ __ ]
been Speight this is so fascinating
a scale tour okay let's do a scale tour
whoa what is that that is a Riggle Rijal
I don't know how to say that a better a
better little poem a serious Jesus
Christ
all right what are we there's the
tiniest one what is that all right well
there's Mars Mars is pretty [ __ ] big
Jesus Christ look at that that's our son
Sirius which I don't know what it is
Arcturus Rijal and better look out
Bethel Gauss Canis Majoris Jesus Christ
I want a Google Ad Canis Majoris
this is a great tool for learning
imagine being a kid and just exploring
this you'd learn way more than [ __ ]
school that's for sure
that's pretty cool ha ha ha ha damn Oh
God moon where are you going Moon Moon
Oh
[Music]
damn god damn this is so [ __ ] cool I
like the whole video me just bet this is
so cool but seriously this is so cool
in a really weird way the universe feel
like it makes sense when you play oh god
what is happening oh other crashing I
did not expect to be so blown away well
I will I downloaded this I was just like
I [ __ ] it I'll try it okay Bruce you
know what just just try it this game out
yourself if you have a decent computer I
highly recommend it
hope you guys enjoyed this episode I'm
gonna keep playing but I'll have to end
it there alright
anyway think it was so much for watching
I will see you in